[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 76 of
the weekly Google apart from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I am good how are you doing
today I'm very happy to be back to San
Francisco with nice weather and
everything after a pretty awesome week
in New York yeah very nice sounds like
I've got a bit of fun over there yeah
very excited to be talking again but
kubernetes last week we had hank
goldberg from gke talking about why
container engine is open source and the
difference between container engine
kubernetes and this week we have Daniel
Smith a software engineer working in the
kubernetes team to talk about all the
cool new things that come in with
kubernetes 106 we've came out not that
long ago
no just several weeks ago yeah basically
Daniel and I nerd out for about 20
minutes on communities yeah and I try to
understand some of the things I use
cover Nettie's but like I keep it like
very like the basics if you're
interested on the really the newest
things they're like deep technical
topics this episode is going to be for
you I'm sure you will enjoy it and then
at the end we have a question of the
week which is kind of cool is but like
what do you do when you create a Google
cloud platform project yeah what are the
first things yeah personally so we will
answer them personally yeah because we
actually don't agree but you know
whatever that's good we'll talk about
that at the end but before that we have
the cool things of the week and the
first one is about this new program it's
called cloud on board basically is a
full training event that's going to be
happening all around the world for now
it's being announced the dates and
places for North America so we'll have a
link in the show notes and I think that
there's a bunch of them I think I saw
Austin got Dallas Austin and Toronto
there should be more coming I expect
there's 12 cities in US and Canada
oh yeah Chicago Vancouver San Francisco
LA Seattle Atlanta Boston Washington DC
and New York City
so bunch of them and even better than
that there's actually also more events
on this type so you can go and learn
more about Google cloud platform all
around the world so I know that I'll be
attending one in
actually I'm going to ask mark to say
the capital of Argentina I massacred
this before
bonus eres no bonus artists when Osiris
that's very good yeah there you go
so Buenos Aires will be one of those
places but I'm sure we'll be many more
that will be announcing something soon
so just listen to the podcast and we let
you know yeah free full-day training
programs yeah they're really cool so
pretty excited about those the second
cool thing of the week is a very cool
thing of the week
it's ipv6 yeah so we've got ipv6 finally
supported or we have beta it's in beta
ipv6 termination for HPS load balancing
SSL proxy and TCP Park C load balancing
yeah so if you have ipv6 needs we are
able to provide those for you yeah
because you know I think that this year
is the last year like this year is the
year of leanness on the desktop and the
real we'll run out of ipv4 addresses I
think this is the same year Linux on the
desktop is coming yeah yeah yeah soon
absolutely so yeah if you want to use
ipv6 which I definitely recommend
there's actually a couple conferences
that already moved completely to ipv6
Fossum is one of them now interesting
kind of cool it forces you to up to
update a lot of different things but
yeah if you want to use it check it out
we'll have a link in the show notes and
then the last cool thing of the week
comes from metadata mail which a
developer advocate Google cloud platform
specialized in dotnet technologies and
he's based in London if I don't if I
remember correctly and he wrote a really
cool blog post on G RPC specifically
from the point of view of everybody says
the G RPC is really good to have inter
operation or support to have multiple
prime languages in the same system is
that actually true so he talks about how
to make something that you have a server
brain in Java and the client is actually
been in dotnet actually using c-sharp
evironment correctly and it is really
cool and actually if you don't know G
RPC that much we have a couple episodes
G RPC I think yeah we do so episode 15 G
RPC with foreign tell rpm for GRP see
here we go through that hmm we also have
a great chat with Brandon Phillips from
core OS and episode 43 oh yeah that was
which was really really good and in
episode 53 we have one of our fellow
developer advocates Sandeep Dinesh comes
and join us and talks about how he and I
put together the game Simon and use G
RPC to make it oh yeah Simon says that
yeah make it very scalable and
multiplayer over the Internet
yeah so check it out I'm going to be
talking about G RPC more often now
because I did a little demo with go and
it is an amazing experience is really
nice no I agree completely so yeah check
it out took the episodes that we have
all of those things in the show notes as
usual so yeah why don't we go have a
chat with Daniel about kubernetes we
should probably give a little small
provider before we jump in yeah because
Daniel and I do nerd out a lot about
some of the more advanced features that
have come in communities so if you are
new to kubernetes don't feel like these
are features you have to use these are
really just there for if the default
things like services and deployments
aren't necessarily working for you in
the way that you need it to for your
very specific workload yeah this is the
configuration options that kubernetes
gives you didn't able to tailor to
exactly what you need but if you're just
getting started kubernetes maybe have a
listen keep it in the back ear head in
case one day you're like oh there was
this thing I might need but if you're
just getting started it's interesting
but you don't have to worry about yeah I
think that is telling that these are
features that were not included in
kubernetes until version 1.6 as many
people are using in production already
so very probably you don't need them but
if you want to know about them
dan is here to tell us about it cool so
let's go chat with him so I'm very happy
to welcome to the podcast
daniel smith daniel you are a software
engineer and tl a tech lead or tim lead
i am a trainer adventurer at some random
weird part of kubernetes gke tell us
about it what do you do what do you do
at Google
hi yeah yeah honestly I'm not sure what
teal is regular so I'm the tail of the
API machinery sub team at Cooper
Nettie's we've broken the teeth as the
kubernetes team has grown we've broken
it into a bunch of small groups smallish
groups so my my group is the API
machinery group and our goal is to take
care of the API machinery so this is
this is
the stuff the sort of the guts of
kubernetes the plumbing between clients
and servers and between the server and
the storage back-end making client
libraries making this the stuff that
lets people write new api's who so does
that mean you're responsible for client
- go yeah I've used that yeah oh good it
was good I used it it was it worked well
we will try not to go over what what I
think about gos dependency management
system okay so let's continue to talk
about something else so we have you
today to talk about the latest
kubernetes version criminais is 1.6 I
was going to say 1.8 because that is go
but now it is 1.6 and I also will talk
at some point the fact that you just
migrated also to kubernetes just
migrated to go under date so pretty
happy about that so what it what is new
in kubernetes 1.6 what is the biggest
pieces of information you think
everybody should know if you look at our
documentation we've got a number of
areas we've increased the scale
Federation is to beta our back is to
beta our back as a security feature
there's some new scheduling tricks that
you can do few other things I would
let's talk about scale because obviously
scale in Federation there seem to be two
fairly hot topics
I believe communities now goes up to
5,000 nodes is that correct yeah that's
correct
so we now enforce our are we we promised
our SLO over 5,000 notes 5,000 node
clusters this and and the SLO is we
respond the control plane responds to
API requests in under a second 99% of
the time I was going to say so that's
this interesting can you tell us
actually like how that was possible like
what what actually changed is there
changes under the hood or what happened
there so that that would be possible so
that that good that can happen
yeah the scalability team made a bunch
of changes to make this happen one of
the larger ones is switching to at CD
version 3 we were previously on at CD 2
that was actually a pretty large effort
that was done by voice check and Poland
my own team member Matt here put in a
lot of work getting that set up and we
had lots of help from friends at Korres
is it is it true that at cv3
one of the biggest changes is that it
actually uses G RPC instead of rest is
that what you think brought the the
performance gain so that's that's
actually a detail about the sed client
library so yes it does it does use a G
RPC but we actually got that benefit
just by switching to the client library
so at CD itself scales better if you if
you use the version 3 format oh nice
very cool um and like we know
Federation's are pretty big things with
kubernetes can you tell us sort of a
what is what is creepin ADEs Federation
and be like what's new in 1.6 that we
can take advantage of now you know after
you get a cluster to a certain size it
becomes very problematic if something
goes wrong right so after a certain size
it's better to start running multiple
clusters and and
you know you don't want the blast radius
to be too big if something happens to
your control plane so Federation is a
way of presenting multiple clusters
under a single control plane it's not
new we've had it for a while but it is
square it is growing up and I think it
went to beta this time around and it can
do it can do some things like manage
pods for you manage replication
controllers I think it's got services so
you can you can sort of manage multiple
clusters at the same time how does it
look when you use Federation does that
mean that cube CTL has a special mode so
you when you deploy deploys to the world
or what does it look like yeah I so I'm
a little bit in danger of telling you
stuff I don't know but yeah you point
you point your Q control you set your
cube config file to point to the
Federation control plane and and it's
got its own set of controllers that just
maintain configuration like say you want
a you want a service to run in multiple
clusters you can make a looks just like
the regular config file from kubernetes
and there's maybe a couple extra fields
that help it find how many how many
clusters in which clusters you want it
to run nice so I guess that seems brief
talked about how you can run bigger jobs
through both larger clusters and also
many classes for Federation the next
thing that you mentioned was our back
what it what is our back what does it
stand for
ah what does it stand for how about I
tell you what sounds good
role is it role based access control
yeah role based access control yeah that
makes sense
so basically kubernetes is starting to
grow up and we're getting more
fine-grained control over security when
people think of security I think there's
sort of two topics that that covers one
is identity or what we call
authentication and the other is
permissions or what we call
authorization and so our back is about
authorization it is a way of specifying
sort of really really fine-grained
permissions on various aspects of your
of your cluster so you could you can
specify a like a resource verb and an
actor a person or a group and say you
know yes you can do this no you can't
and so this is more fine-grained than
we've had previously well I think we've
had our back previously but it's going
to beta this time around so it's kind of
like I I am but for kubernetes
specifically yeah it is exactly like I
am for kubernetes it is more
fine-grained okay cool so if I'm a large
organization and I want to have certain
maybe senior developers who are able to
push the production but maybe my more
junior people I'm going to let them push
to dev or staging then I've got controls
there that I'm able to take advantage of
to do that yeah absolutely
what's the the authorization hooks
they're like should I be able to hook
that into I don't know like an LDAP
system or my own custom authentication
or what's available there kubernetes
supports multiple ways of getting
identity so LDAP is a will give you
identity if you if you're running a GAE
installation then you get identity from
the Google system one of the things we
added is a subject access review API so
you can actually if you have permission
to do it you can you can actually call a
kubernetes control plane and ask does
this person have permission to do this
thing on this on this cluster sure okay
cool so the thing that I'm actually
personally quite excited about and
something I've been playing with a bit
is the advanced scheduling stuff I think
this is super super cool
there's there several different things
here um which one do we want to talk
about first so there's a whole bunch of
stuff around pod affinity that I think
is really interesting can you tell us
about that I was reading about it last
night just make sure I understood it
there's a couple different affinity
settings there's there's affinity for
notes an affinity for pods affinity for
nodes is like you know you'd prefer or
you you must your your pod prefers a
particular node or a must schedule on a
particular node pod affinity is even
more interesting that is for situations
where you want to be co-located with a
with another set of pods or you want to
be not co-located with with the set of
pods so pod affinity is for when you
want to schedule taking account of the
other pods that are on a node or in an
availability zone so it's if you have
pods that need to be scheduled together
or shouldn't be scheduled together
suppose you have workloads that need
high bandwidth communication between
each other like you're doing some sort
of machine learning something and you
want them to be in a network segment
that has high connectivity so you you
may you can set up labels on your node
saying like what your topology is and
you can sort of select over what other
what other pods have been scheduled in
this topology section and do I want to
be scheduled close to those pods or
maybe you want to spread for disaster
tolerance you you could say I want to be
scheduled away from these other pods so
an interesting question then so I can
have multiple containers running inside
a given pod why would I choose to use
pod affinity to bring other pods
together versus putting them all
together in the same pod just with
multiple containers what what benefits
do I get there
I think that's really for very different
use cases like if you're putting
multiple things inside one pod you're
saying that your scaling is literally
one-to-one if you know if you have like
I don't know a web front-end and a data
base sinker in one pod you are getting
exactly one of those one of each every
time you scale up or scale down if you
have services that need to scale
separately but still be co-located like
maybe you've got
one database that serves several
different web services the services may
need to be close to the database but you
don't want to scale one to one so in
that case you want separate pods for
each so you're talking about on the pod
side you've got ways to coordinate where
pods should be close to each other or
affinity against each other but then you
can also control things on the node side
as well is that right yeah yeah so
there's a new beta feature no taints and
I like to think of this as like the
role-playing game sense of like the node
is tainted by some some dark magic this
is a this is you you're basically
setting a flag on the on the node and
then the system will prevent any pod
that doesn't tolerate that flag from
landing on the node so you could use
this for like if you've got nodes that
have GPUs or local SSD and you want
normal pods not to schedule on those
because you want to you want to leave
you want to leave those free for
workloads that really take advantage of
the unique feature so you could you
could taint those those nodes would say
you know GPU true and then only pods
that actually say I tolerate the GPU
tank and can land there you can use this
to do all sorts of cool stuff along the
same lines there's a alpha feature so
the system is continuously health
checking nodes and after a while it will
like if a node stops calling if a note
stops phoning home the system will set
its status to unknown and if it doesn't
doesn't come back it will eventually
just kick all the pods off of the node
you can now set some flags and treat
that event as a taint itself so you can
sort of control how long your pods will
are willing to tolerate a note that is
possibly unresponsive so the question I
kind of had is like it sounds like pod
affinity and node taints kind of do the
same things but it from different
directions when should I choose one over
the other I think clearly if you if you
want to if you want your pods to do
stuff based on other pods in the system
then you definitely want to use pod
affinity if you want your pas
adds to schedule depending on facts
about your nodes then you probably want
to use node taints the other distinction
is taints are for keeping pods off of
nodes and affinity is for getting pods
onto nodes so if you really want to set
up an exclusive relationship you need
both all right so the the final thing on
the event schedule stuff which is also
kind of interesting is custom schedulers
I mean up until this point communities
has kind of had the scheduler which has
kind of been the one true way but now
you can kind of mess with it a bit
what's that all about
so specifically this feature is you
leave the default scheduler running and
you start up your own scheduler beside
it you can set with a field in your in
your pods which scheduler you would like
your pods to be scheduled by and you can
do this I don't know maybe maybe if
you've got some special logic that isn't
covered by affinity or taints or
readying it like if you've got something
custom that needs to happen you can
write a scheduler that does that for you
and then you can have your pods go
through that scheduler instead of the
default one and I think I saw one of our
teammates Ian Lewis help out with a blog
post for the kubernetes blog I will link
to it in the show notes we're in I think
I saw yeah he wrote a custom scheduler
in bash so that doesn't seem to be a
limit on the language that you can write
your custom schedulers are in is that is
that correct you know one of the one of
the best things about kubernetes I think
is is just the fact that our api's are
truly open like there's no secret api's
all of the all the stuff that the
default system components do is stuff
you can do and you know you can do it
through the go client library you can do
it through cube control and bash doesn't
the system doesn't really doesn't really
care what's on the other end of the API
we're starting to come out with
libraries and other languages there's a
pretty full-featured Python library now
so yeah you you can write it in bash I
wouldn't recommend it but that's what we
wrote cool so I had a question regarding
not scheduling anymore but sometimes you
want to scale your cluster you need more
volumes you need storage the only way to
create this is either you created by
yourself or you want to create it
like automatically and I think they
wandered for dynamic provisioning was
added and there's something new about it
but I don't know what it is what's going
on with an emic storage provision so I
think this this feature is pretty
awesome let me give some background on
the storage system in communities
because a large part of kubernetes is
workload portability right we want you
to be able to write your application
targeted at kubernetes and then run it
in multiple cloud environments now it
turns out that multiplied environments
don't all do storage volumes the same
way so to get around this we have a a
concept which is persistent volume and
we have another concept called
persistent volume claim and the idea is
you write your workload to talk to a
persistent volume claim and you allocate
persistent volumes from the cloud
provider so if you go to a different
cloud provider all that has to change is
the logic that's producing the volumes
like your application doesn't doesn't
even notice and so what's new here is
that there's this there's a storage
class that's introduced a storage class
object and that is basically a thing
that can automatically produce
persistent volumes so it frees cluster
administrators from having to do that
nice so I'm curious about you mentioned
the storage claim could that be seen as
basically the API that someone needs to
satisfy to be able to provide storage
volumes for kubernetes which means that
basically like there's one for Google
Cloud but also if you want to run it on
other cloud provider or even on premise
that's what you should be implementing
so if you wanted to support kubernetes
to a particular cloud environment the
thing that you want to produce is a
controller controller logic so so I
haven't looked at I haven't looked at
the dynamic storage provisioning feature
in like a code level but there must be a
controller and if you wanted to port to
a different cloud environment you would
write an implementation of that
controller
cool the
would look for like unsatisfied claims
against a storage class and then you'd
select the appropriate like volume
setting size etc from your cloud
environment cool um is there any other
like I know the mean those seem to be
the big highlights I think we've covered
there but are there any other like
little things that have also been added
that are kind of cool and interesting
sort of some under the hood stuff I
think is probably worth mentioning a
bunch of work has been done in something
called a container runtime interface and
this this this effort is is probably not
super user visible but it will make some
things easier for us in the future and
basically the idea is cubelet which is
the node agent has two responsibilities
basically like on one side it's it's
talking to the kubernetes api and
getting workloads and reporting back etc
and on the other side it's talking to
the container runtime which is usually
docker and as starting starting
containers stopping them so the
container runtime interfaces is effort
is to sort of split this down the middle
and let the container runtime part of
that be out of process - Cupit so that
it's easier for for people to implement
that couplet can focus on correctly
implementing the kubernetes api another
another cool thing that that couplet is
doing and this I'm I'm excited about
this because it is fixing a
long-standing issue that we've had some
times is couplet is now declaring space
for system demons called this feature
node allocatable and the idea is you
know the system components like cubelet
itself docker other demons that are
running on the system they take up some
ram they take up some cpu and if you
don't take that into account the
scheduler will stuff so much stuff on to
the node that it will go out a memory
and start killing things
so it's it's pretty cool to have have
this put in to the node stats so that
the scheduler can take account of this
and not over overload nodes cool um now
we've think we've covered all the stuff
that's pretty much available and in beta
but we've had some new alpha features as
well that I know I know we don't
necessarily support out of the box
without clicking some checkboxes and
saying this is fine if you set yourself
on fire
Jr took it yeah you can make an alpha
cluster but you can get great it's all
on you but yeah what what new alpha
features are available right now so one
thing I'm excited about is out of tree
cloud providers which is we're splitting
our there's multiple control plane
components and kubernetes and one of
them is called a controller manager that
sort of groups all the various
controllers that are that are running
the system kubernetes is kind of built
out of this control loop pattern where
we have these these components that that
basically are doing one thing and
they're there watching you know they're
watching your replica said it wants five
pods they're looking at the cluster you
only have four so it'll make a new one
the whole system is built out of this
sort of control loop we're sort of
splitting that binary up so that the
ones that are specific and married to a
to a cloud provider are in a different
binary so that you can run the standard
controller manager binary and also the
one appropriate for your for your cloud
environment if you were doing a
bare-metal installation or something you
could just take a look at that skeleton
see what it provides and write your own
implementation another thing I'm excited
about which is which is a alpha support
is GPUs so we handle GPUs as resources
on doats now could you tell us a little
bit more about it what does it look like
to say I want to use GPUs like let's say
there's someone that wants to do like
video game stuff and they need the video
rendering of stuff how does like you
know I haven't played with that
particular feature so hey I'm really not
the best person to ask you know I
thought it was targeted more towards
machine learning Oh interesting so maybe
maybe it probably also works for for
people who need to do renders but I
think it's targeted towards a good
morning the more more exposure of the
queue to stuff and that kind of stuff in
those sort of like Nvidia cards and
things like that yeah I don't know that
we go into that level of detail I think
it's just the couplet notes that hey
I've got this many GPUs available and
then the scheduler can see that pods
want you know one to a few GPUs and it
can it can track that as a resource cool
one more question wanted to ask you is
do you know a little bit about how was
it to migrate to go on the date was it
an easy thing or
yeah so so we did just get to go 1.8 I
think we got there yesterday maybe the
day before so kubernetes 1.6 is still
built with 1.7 but how in head we are on
go 1.8 and it seems cool so far I've
been running it on my personal system
for a while I'm excited to see more cool
yeah we are running out of time a bit
but uh what's on the road map for
kubernetes going forward I saw there
have been dropped some 1.74 like alpha
releases and stuff but what sort of
stuff can we see coming down the
pipeline I'll just focus on what what I
and my team are working on I think we've
got some cool stuff planned as something
that the sorts of things that get me
excited and kubernetes are the things
that make it easier for the ecosystem to
develop and and for us to get more
components that op interoperate with
kubernetes and so in that vein we're
working on API aggregation this is the
idea that you can like take your own API
and aggregate it seamlessly with the
kubernetes api we have various folks in
the ecosystem like OpenShift
who basically are operating something
that's very very similar to kubernetes
but it's actually a it's actually a fork
if you look under the hood like like
they have very painful emerges when
kubernetes increments version so so the
idea here is is the people who want to
add this sort of api can run it on top
of kubernetes instead of operating a
fork and this this should make it much
easier to add api's you should be able
to add multiple API is in the same
cluster so yeah this is what I'm looking
forward to is that like link to like
third-party resources is that kind of in
that that same vein as people who want
to add their own resources to
communities and make it do special
things yeah it is it is similar and this
was a really hot topic last quarter on
if you poke around the API machinery sig
Docs you'll find one that I put out
there that was comparing and contrasting
the two I think the the short story is
that kubernetes needs both third party
resources and API creation going forward
third party resources
the target audience there is it's really
easy to get something up and running
doesn't take a lot of a lot of effort
it works with Q control already so it's
like low effort easy to use not
necessarily full-featured and the idea
with aggregation API aggregation is a
little bit more heavyweight probably
you're only going to do this if you
really want to fundamentally alter or
add some some really fundamental API
concept but you would you would do this
we offer we're going to offer a library
you'd compile you'd run your own API
server you you make an entry in the
aggregation API and then that that would
get integrated with Q control and if you
do things that way you'll get all the
all the power of the API system so you
can do all the fancy validation you want
you can write super custom admission
controller you can do strange defaulting
anything you like right I think that
we're free out of time by now so thank
you so much for taking the time to tell
us a little bit about all the cool
things that I come in with kubernetes
1.6 it's very interesting
cool thanks for having me yeah thank you
so much so thanks Daniel for such an
interesting conversation there was a lot
of those things that I'm not sure I
completely understood what they were for
because you know like there's really
advanced stuff there if you felt that
way
do not fear that's normal I guess but
thanks yeah thanks it was really really
interesting and it makes you think about
like all of those little features that
probably will no need but the day you'll
need them they're they're cool so why
don't we have a chat about the question
of the week so this would be a bit
interesting if we just talk a little bit
about so you create a Google cloud
platform project yeah what's the first
thing you do let me say my things first
god so normally what I do is I create my
project all the time from the console
from console the cloud or girl.com
I do the same and then what I do is I go
to my terminal and they do g-cloud init
to set up all the configuration so
whenever I do anything from G code it
will be actually referring to that yep
and I do this partly because I have
three different accounts linked to me
yup so I want to make sure that
I do what I do in the project that I'm
trying to otherwise you'll get errors
and it's it's kind of knowing do you use
configurations or do you just use the
just read like Rio on the same account
uh yeah I do not use configurations okay
I just a real and it's very easy it
works pretty well there's a product
manager for jiggle out here I wish that
I could have directory dependent
configurations that would be nice
consider ended up as a feature request
each request from the podcast but yeah
just g-cloud init and that works pretty
well and then well right after that I'm
going to go to to the console again and
seems very often what I'm doing is I'm
going to be running somehow compete and
compete the engine instances and you
need to activate that API what I do is I
go to the compute engine tab and then
just we click in there the API starts
activating that takes a couple minutes
so it's always the first thing you do
you don't pay for having it activated so
even like ireally is like sometimes it
deploy in App Engine as you will
activate the update my habit just kiss
you know that's what I do but yeah
that's pretty much it and then check
that like billing account is set up and
all of this thing so I can actually
start working on the project directly
what about you so I'm basically doing
that I set up my project through consult
or cloud or Google comm you know you
don't use the deployment manager for
that so you could you could I know you
can I haven't I haven't played with that
yet but I may one day soon in fact maybe
I will maybe I will do that about it
because I have a few steps so the first
thing I to actually is I make sure I
have multiple owners on the account I
started with my email address and then I
have a secondary email address that I
use to make sure there are multiple
emails on the account just in case
always a good thing to have just in case
one account something happens to it yeah
and then you can still have access to
your projects ideally multiple people is
a good idea but yeah multiple owners is
always good and then basically this is
like not really a step but that make
sure that the emails the owners of my
accounts I make sure those are email
accounts that I actually look at on a
regular basis because if anything goes
bad with your project in fact we had a
conversation with the abuse team at one
point yeah right if anything bad happens
to your project say somebody compromises
when your systems or something like that
happens then that's the email address
you're going to get a message at - so
you want to receive those those really
important because otherwise you can get
your project shut down and that would be
sad yeah and that would make you very
very sad so definitely I like having
multiple owners and making sure that
those emails are monitored going back to
the topic you were talking about abuse
and support yeah
reading those emails is really important
yeah because you know when you receive
one of those emails they're actually
important and you need to answer them
there's two episodes where we cover a
little bit about this and the best
practices on like how to make sure that
your projects are following the terms of
services and all these things there's
episode 47 with cloud abuse and we had
SWAT equal shrift and a maker Congo and
then on episode 24 we also had Terrence
Shepherd talking about Google apartment
support we yeah we cover all the little
things that you may want to do
especially I'd say that the biggest
piece of advice is make sure those
emails do not go to like some account
that nobody reads yeah don't send to dev
know like yeah that's that
yeah well franceska it's wonderful
talking with you again where are you
going to be in the next few weeks
what are you up to so next week it will
be here in San Francisco for gopher fest
that's gonna be on Monday and after that
I will be on my way to some really quick
holidays and by the end of the month
I'll go to Buenos Aires for the on board
event that's gonna be pretty cool and
next I will be going to Q come I'm
actually very excited about that
I have this video go tooling in action
yep that pre popular and I'm making a
workshop out of that and I'll be running
it on cue con New York that's very sad
but that that'd be at the end of June
what about you so next week I will be up
to Sweden for Nordic games conference
which should be lots of fun I'll make a
shout out I'm not going to be there but
if anyone's in San Francisco on Saturday
the second part of the play crafting and
Extra Life Game Jam is their game fest
which is this weekend cool and basically
it's a free event for 24 hours you can
go play games they're gonna be streaming
stuff just basically raising money for
kids in hospitals so super super cool
and it's in launchpad space here in San
Francisco
make sure we'll link to that and then my
guru on some holidays for a bit as well
actually very nice yeah I heard that
there's this little event Google IO
oh yeah that is coming up isn't it yeah
you will not be attending I will not be
attending I will be in Sweden I will not
be attending okay
but I know that many of you might be
attending let us know how it goes we're
going to be interviewing some people
about some things that might be
happening at Google i/o and you'll have
an episode on that after that was very
very good like it I know it's very good
nobody knows what's going on and what's
great as we could [ __ ] in anybody and no
one would know exactly things marks so
much for such an amazing episode I feel
like these episode without you would
have been way harder cuz we didn't know
what we're talking about so thank you so
much and thank you to you Francesca and
thank you very much to everyone who's
listening see y'all next week
see you all next week
you